proprio perché perché io già mi devo so
già che mi deve incazzare vabbè lasciamo
perdere
siamo tornati suam per mario ragazzi ok
perfetto di sopra perché devono cadere
le cose non potevate mettere degli
ostacoli nei mini blocchino nel terreno
gli ostacoli dimettono nella terra
guarda vara sono morto lì lo stesso
punto di prima
ok aspettarci di proprio nuovo fatto blu
come lo fa perché aiuta nel punto di
prima niente ogni volta che sbaglio mi
auto punisco così non sbaglio più come
ha fatto e cosa devo fare qua quello
incazzato ma rimane incazzato check
point
se sì l'ho preso via via via a caso a
caso perché bravo
guarda che fenomeno bravissimo un
fenomeno raga un fenomeno deciso così un
fenomeno fenomeno adesso faccio tutto da
solo tutto qualche bravo 40
[Musica]
pensavo di dover fare il 6 invece avevo
già fatto le 7 mag
[Musica]
bene la partenza delle migliori
aggiungerei a questo è proprio e proprio
terreno cosparso di ostacoli a caso
quindi fantastico ok tempo
effettivamente potevo farne a meno
perfetto giunge subito perfetto buono
buono come sua madre
[Musica]
ok ok allora adesso andiamo su
direttamente sopra non si può andare
sopra ci sono le spine
ok posso andarci sopra no allora vado
giugno se non puoi andare sopra e non
prendere giu tua madre muore parlo al
creatore del gioco sempre per carità
niente
[Musica]
la parte poi è frustrante da fare perché
deve aspettare che tutte ste
tartarughine della minkia vada al di là
a fare i cavoli loro
poi salti qua poi salti la e poi muori
uguale perché sono un deficiente ragazzi
ve lo giuro su quello che volete è molto
più difficile di quanto mi ricordassi
porca eva ma daily che devo andare non
posso andare da altre parti
[Musica]
lo prego prego preso l'ho preso va bene
va bene va bene così ok ok dai madonna
ma per una volta che faccio le cose
senza ripetere le 600 volte dai già
stavo facendo pure madonna guardali
cos'era successo
[Musica]
ma perché ci sono i così che cadono per
terra dove devo andare
[Musica]
non è vero non ditemi che non è successo
vi prego ditemi che non è successo vi
prego garantiscono farò mai più
ma perché ma come ho fatto prima una
veloce giuro sto sudando freddo
no no no dai basta sta cosa dai vai
guardate che sorpresa sono morto o se io
ti devi ricorda la sequenza allora salto
poi sottosopra 12 sotto subito no sotto
qui no allora sotto no 12
ok
[Musica]
non lo so ora che non lo so vado a casa
ma vaffan
poi quando vado a caso non è che dici
una volta mi va bene che riescono
proprio mori e perché devi morire da del
primo dove sono finiti dove chi guarda
guarda guarda 4 la mia fare caso proprio
ma guarda lo schifo nella terra proprio
che deve fare sto gioco non la melma
adesso ci arrivava in scia a distanza di
cinque schifosi anni ho deciso di rifare
a fermare o cioè non potevo stare nel
mio fare le cose nuove no riprendere i
giochi vecchi perché la gente vuole
rivedermi scala potuto genio aspetta che
ci stanno le cose fanno i loro comodi
[Musica]
check point da qualche parte nel mondo
della vita check point per farmi finire
la mia vita come vogliono
sta succedendo cos'è check point per
cortesia per cortesia
[Musica]
guardali madonna era il finale ragazze
del finale ma annuncia però mai non c'è
un checkpoint in tutto li punisce un
checkpoint in tutto il livello non c'è
un centro di tutto livello non c'è un
check point ragazze non ce l'ho
accettato tutto il livello senza come
getting over il tutto diverso una grana
della maga tutto senza c'è poi tutto era
solo una questo indie credo interiore
capito però veloce voce ma bonotto mappe
bagni vi denuncio
ci arrivo
ma perché dai dai basta basta sì credo
si sta credendo te lo giuro
ok finisci però c'è finisci oggi quanto
mai quanto manca prima della fine del
gioco mi fate sapere per favore grazie
[Musica]
cosa vedo
c'è un cubetto quale ricavati da morire
la famiglia mai possibile non ci passi
assolutamente se non ci sarei riuscito
quella roba lì a sinistra deve esserci o
no dai dai dai dai ti prego ti prego
porca vacca salta torna su dai madonna
dai madonna
bravissimo bravissimo così ti voglio
voglio tornare ad avere una vita di
nuovo arciprete dovesse dove come avevo
fatto
no
[Musica]
rigorosamente controllare di non essermi
fatto fratture però vale cos'è l'ultimo
ne avete anche cambiato la colonna
sonora conto 75 guarda mi aspettavo
proprio tu stai dicendo
aspetta aspetta aspetta sci zitti
desistero mazzi
[Musica]
e finito su re tra non come cosa ho
vinto no non sto capendo il giorno
[Musica]
ma no sono volati in cielo quindi non
sono morto
[Musica]
leve completa space for next level
nextlevel poi ci sono morto e non so
[Musica]
l'ho finito no non ho capito
hanno forse da domandare a sinistra per
qua non lo so non sto capendo dare aiuto
you want finished level danny way
cosa vuol dire quando l'avevo fatto la
prima volta ma scusami un attimo ma
[Musica]
sì sì sì
cinque anni di menzogne fermare non
l'avevo mai finito non e vero quello non
era fine di affermare non è la fine
io io io per cinque anni ho creduto di
avere finita un fair mario e non lo
avevo finito paga guarda va bene
sono rimasto scioccato da questa cosa io
credo che le cose che non si che sono in
computer devono rimane debbano rimanere
incompiuta è una scusa per non finire
veramente mi sono fratturato un polso
quindi spero ragazzi ai video vi sia
piaciuto è concluso qua ma se invece
come mi piace che riceve dalle
iscrizioni sono sapere studiare e non ci
vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]